I'd like to know who
here you trust the least.
Marysol asked so you can start.
I think I trust Nicole the least.
Marysol, you are bored in your life.
Who the **** are you?
Hmm.
Just stay out of it like you normally do.
Buckle up baby.
It's gonna be a bumpy ride!
This season on the Real Housewives of Miami.
Bet you never thought you'd see me again.
It's the largest penthouse in the U.S.
How much am I paying for this?
$50K a night.
This is the best city in the entire world.
Living in Miami, you can be you
and people accept it.
Martina Navratilova, she's my wife.
Surprise!
I feel like Adriana is like a mosquito.
I just want to, like, swat her away.
Pens out, **** out, let's go!
Where are my hookers?
Woah!
Ooh, Nikki, grrr!
I'm obsessed with my OnlyFans.
What are you up to today?
If you're making $10,000 a day,
you're showing more.
Back off, girly!
Oh my God, you're very aggressive.
Somebody told me that he died
while having sex with a man.
My dad got sent to jail.
You show up obviously intoxicated.
What do you mean? I'm not, I'm,
I'm, I'm not intoxic–
You can't even say the word!
I do want to get divorced.
Does he want you back?
I lost my brother.
And his wife?
Two of his three kids.
It was an earthquake.
We still have the spark, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah?
Absolutely.
Just because you decided to, like, dive into
this world of being married doesn't mean
I have to participate in all of this ********.
I grew up in this town, I know everyone.
And you and your husband
are talking a lot of ****.
You left this group of women,
come back with a butt as
big as Kim Kardashian's,
trying to become the new
Kim Kardashian,
which you're never gonna be.
You're a loser.
You're gonna wind up in jail.
If you say that one more time
I'm gonna beat you up!
I'll fight you back!
911 is coming!
Oh no. Oh my God.
She was preparing for the worst,
and then the worst happened.
On the wedding day.